thank you so much hi everyone
so 36.5 a durational performance with
the CE is a series of nine site-specific
performances and video artworks made in
collaboration with communities around
the world where I have stood in bodies
of water for a full title cycle between
12 and 13 hours each time
and it all began as a poetic response to
Hurricane Sandy hitting New York City in
October of 2012 because what happened
was I suddenly understood just how
vulnerable we were we know that
civilizations come and go intellectually
but could my beloved City disappear in
my lifetime what was water trying to
tell us about the Future these were the
questions I was asking and I kept
imagining this little artist or any
person really running around the city
trying to make ends meet and the city's
just sinking beneath her feet
and I kept on thinking about this
parallel between the struggle for an
individual to survive on a daily basis
and the struggle for Humanity to survive
in the face of the climate crisis
and then nine months later I'm up in
Maine and I realized that the tides
could function as a metaphor for sea
level rise
so one day I walk out I low tide and I
let the water rise up to my chin and
then I let it go back down again over
the course of 12 hours and 48 minutes
and I didn't know if I would make it
through this whole cycle but there was
an important moment when the water was
high and I understood in my body just
how connected we all are and I thought
if I'm this little person in New York
City thinking about these things what is
someone in Bangladesh or Kenya thinking
about and I promised myself that if I
made it through the cycle I would create
this in collaboration with communities
around the world and so that's what
happened nine years nine bodies of water
hundreds of collaborators thousands of
participants a global project was a
local approach and here's what I learned
I learned about deep listening to the
water the more the human world to the
people and all other living beings who
live near the water and from my
indigenous collaborators around the
world I learned about decentering the
human or just one species after all and
reframing water as our tin and relation
rather than as a resource
and they really taught me about engaging
in Daily practice of gratitude
reciprocity asking permissions in
relation to the water the land and
ancestors
and I learned about deep time and
long-term thinking my work has always
been based around ideas of time
questions about expanding and
Contracting time but with 36.5 I started
to really look at the ancient past in
order to try to understand the long term
but perhaps not so distant future we
have with Rising Seas
and then on an individual scale I
learned about feeling time as a sensory
experience because it's one thing to
consider climate change intellectually
and it's a completely different thing to
feel the water rise on your body over
the course of a day or to witness this
happening because we know everything is
temporary and we're only here on this
planet for a short amount of time and I
try to recognize the Beauty and the
terror of this fact
what can I do in my short little flip of
a life and for me it's about tracking
time literally and symbolically on my
body and then connecting with as many
people as possible inviting them to
experience this with me in this act I
find some hope
so now that the performance is for 36.5
are complete there's several outgrowth
exhibitions and a book Etc things
happening and but I'm following one new
thread to explore ideas about living in
ecological time more of the time so I'm
curious to see if I can possibly let go
of the mechanical clock and find a title
clock in my body I'm trying to train
myself to sense the water levels at all
times and tune my body to live in title
time even when I'm not at the water's
edge what can happen if we synchronize
the salty water in our bodies to the
Salt Water that's covering seven tenths
of the planet
could this help us be better prepared
and adapt to future with more water
what if we just need to tune in
thank you so much